the lines are very very busy today Pat
we've got 17 people holding 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 is the number I'm going to go to a
caller who has a very very strange phone
number which leads me to think they may
be calling from another country so
caller from I guess it's country code 23
what's your name and where are you
calling from all dating hello please
speak up we can barely hear you
hon David hi
yeah my name is Jane I'm an attorney
from Nigeria why are you calling from
Nigeria right now yes yes I am
actually I wasn't here show every single
day for the past maybe two years Wow and
I absolutely love it
thank you okay yeah I'm not just going
to say that your kid but you're really
scarred and it's really refreshing to
see young people that you know do not
stick to the norms of the mainstream
media hole like usually have an agenda
but the fact that interview reporting
the way they're supposed to be I
frequently I have family in the United
States but I'm there except not every
year I also saw a red politics a lot and
especially US politics especially
recently and I just want to say thank
you for the way you know your stuff I
did I think it enough show it's amazing
and I just want to say it's full of good
work and you have a lot of sense not
only the United States but also out here
and yeah I want to say thank you
well we're we're Nigeria you're calling
from actually I even Apophis or Abuja
okay and is what's it like there well
first of all I just want to say it's not
at all what people see on the news I
never see any positive thing when
according about Africa or particularly
Nigeria it's always oh my god it's
horrible it's not safe before getting
kidnapped but there's actually a very
large population hundred maybe even
thousands of toilet really care I mean
all over the world including the United
States and most of them who I know I
have a sense that make years ourself and
brought to twenty years are hard because
they come handle I got the smaller what
you will clean up to be and I love it
and I love people and it's completely
okay we do have our own problems but
yeah it's very fine there and I often if
we love it well all I want to say is
it's not at all even close to what it's
made out to be because whenever there's
something like a news about Africa on
Nigeria they always show you the whole
depart for for people can't see the body
corrupt but they let us show you the
progress is made economically and the
fact that things actually going really
well I mean it's not perfect but we're
working on it so yeah people need to
know that well thank you so much for the
call I hope to visit someday and really
really appreciate the kind words first
caller ever from anywhere in Africa
actually is currently from Nigeria so
thank you so much really appreciate to
call back every day yeah thank you
appreciate it
Wow very exciting Pat very very exciting
Patten noting by the way the various
compliments that were made towards me he
has a list that he's keeping over there
so later we can review all of them
together